今日はこちらしている多分です今日も子どもの勉強についてはないでしようと思います
英語英語を上達させすさせるためにですね
英語をメイクやめなさい
九国号勉強しなさい
そういう今日のテーマですね今日はこう言う
れる直下おかしいな提案を使いんですよ
なぜでしょうか
もちろん日本では一番さんお外国王として皆明鏡一生懸命勉強しているな英語ですよね
大部分がほとんど
日本に行く時に本屋さんいますともういい子の
その勉強ずうためのんたくさんございます
ぽいくどうやってその
点数たくさんとか
トリックの合意女医とか
たくさんありがとう分あるいはいあいあんですから
ak とがあ
そういうものばかりなんですよヒューゴ号とかその他の言葉のローそういう本はねぇ
本屋さんではそんなにないんですよねあるんだけども
英語ほどないんです
日本での佐野英語を中心にした
その
教育システムだですね間違っています
で
あの英語の数字を上げるためにですね
英語をやめて中国語あるいは他の言葉でもいいんですよ
それは韓国をであろうがスペインであろう治雄氏は故穴ぼこ
ぜひ構いませんけれども
第3の言葉を勉強すれば
英語も
さらに蒸着数とを
んですよ冗談じゃないですよ冗談じゃない僕は21殻を割らせる
あるいは勉強した esa ですから
その言葉の勉強というのはそれが一つのスポーツなんですよ
だから脳の柔軟性のぞの言葉の勉強する金利機 t 9
育たないといけないんですよ
で一つの言葉
例えばまあ英語しか話せない人間が
ざんすを日本語中国語名クズ
といい
私の16さんの時例えばですね
あるいは日本の方が日本語しか頭にない人間が
ジャイロバーチューブ他のフォト版を勉強するときにその
日本語の
大日本語のパターンしかないんです
だから
その
はじめの
1本目の外国方が非常におかしい
言葉なぁ
順序が違うんだとか
[音楽]
発音も違うんだとか
非常に抵抗がある
そういうよその新しいシステムですね
導入する
照会数
ことに対してあの
やはり思わずですね
英語が
ただ
第3の言葉を影響するときに
我々の脳がねぇ
少しずつこのあるんですよ
カーゴをするんですよ
うわぁ
この上
その母国ぼ
だけじゃなくて
あるいは例えば園日本人がね我々の発音
我々の構造だけじゃなくて後も存在する
女児映像以外にも台3台4台5の言葉も存在するだから
人間はですね人間が
同じ考えを表現数
ほーしー
無限があるんだ
で
私が一人人間として
どのシステムでもどの構造パターンでもどの発音でも消化できるんだ
勉強できるんだと
そういうその兄式が
それはー
できるとねー
そういうふうに
あの区
脳が感じてくる時に
その今までない柔軟性が脳に
生じてくる
そういう柔軟性があると
新しい言葉を
勉強する自分の
その能力が
上達
その能力が上達するときに
もともとのまぁみろ
英語ないけどのべくも
ば速いすごいですよ
脳がそれだけ広くなったわけですよ
日本日本語をプラス
今度+中国
となったらそれだけ脳が広くなる
そして
どっちどの言葉でも
あの勉強する速さ能力
増えていくなぜかと言うと言葉の勉強というのは記憶力だっじゃないんです
これはになれそれは脳のその柔軟性
ですよだからその柔軟性を探さないといけない
それで中国号は
もちろん
ま代表日本に住んで寺村でて済んでから
日本人であれば
もちろん
中国となりのクリー
すごいラキシすごいもんかー
たくさんの人間 a
いつでも屏風でいきます
優遇その国の言葉はかなり魅力的で
あるんだろう
もちろんもう行き飲酒や場もある ym ずとにアジアもいいし違うよ
j てを後表面という
僕は中国を明記しましたねえ
けれどもボイもし日本人として中国を拒内ですれば当然その言葉は魅力だけであるはず
なんですよ
しかし中京牧羊としているのは中国語に限らず他の
i さんの言語言葉韓国語スペイン語
荒子僕今あらば語研修と教育誤解してましょう
3つの言葉を同時たいるしている同時に勉強してる理由は
さらに自分脳の弾力性柔軟性を
フラしたい
ですその結果新しい現行の桜
そのですね発音を聞いた時に3人
細かいところに気がつくんですよそれだけの公開するに感じてます
だから冗談じゃないよ
英語の勉強英語をさらにその
上達するために栄養の勉強はいったん止めて15頃勉強始めなさい
今日のオーディオの皆さん
可能
良いん
試してみてください jal さよ
ん